what's happening you bad [__]
from the heart of jersey the joint is
brought to you by draftkings the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl let me ask you something you guys
want to win big
because it's starting [__] tomorrow
night starts tomorrow night with tampa
bay against philadelphia then this
weekend you got the denver broncos
against the raiders and monday night you
got buffalo against [__] tennessee
not only that you got baseball playoffs
you got nba
preseason you got college football
listen if you're looking to make some
[__] money this is the time of the
year to do it
draftkings has you covered new customers
can bet one dollar on any nfl game
and whether it wins or loses you get a
hundred dollars in free bets and feed
the team just scores a [__] point
the last zero zero time the nfl was 1943
so i'd say this is a no-brainer
if sportsbook isn't yours isn't in your
state yet draftkings won't leave you
with your dick in your hand everyone can
play for huge cash prizes all season
long with draftkings daily fantasy
sports contests draftkings is giving
away all new customers a free shot out
of millions of [__] dollars and total
prizes you want to win big that's what i
asked you let me tell you something then
i put a 25 dollar parlay on [__]
chicago white sox and the over
i won 92 okay
if you better five time paulie it's 35
to lose 70 to win 70. i'm sorry how the
[__] does draftkings pay you 92 on 25
they pay bigger amounts you better paul
leia same game paul a you're scoring
like a [__] so do me a favor
download the draftking sportsbook app
today your party starts tonight i know
you got some baseball playoffs tonight
tomorrow night you got tampa bay
[__] my man at [__] philadelphia
or the other way around i don't know
what is but it doesn't matter download
the download the draftking sportsbook
app today use promo code joey throw down
a dollar on any nfl game guys and you
win 100 and free bets if either team
scores a point you have to win you have
to do dick
that's promo code joey this weekend
at draftking sports book or better yet
this week the official sports betting
partner the nfl here's the stuff the
lawyer makes me say you ready
[__] you got to be 21 older come
on give me a [__] breather new jersey
indiana pa colorado if they can gamble
we got you down new customers only you
got to have a final deposit with a
minimum of a dollar wager required one
per customer you can't [__] lose
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem
yeah i listen i got your back call 1-800
gambler but if you don't download the
draftking sportsbook app and let's get
this party [__] started if you don't
want to gamble football isn't your thing
how about fantasy download the
draftkings fantasy sportsbook app use
promo code joey and let's win a [__]
million dollars the joint is also
brought to you by c b d lion when it
comes to cbd
cbd lion is the best how do i know
because look look at when this thing
started we had stacks of cbd products
now we're down to the pills a bath ball
a kinesiology tape the vapor pen and the
[__] joint what happened to the
[__] smoke i smoked it what happened
to the other creams i did them because
cbd line is the best they don't [__]
around
read go to cbdline.com and read up on
cbd learn about the advantages of cbn
cby and how they can help you cbn is a
complete different story if you got time
i tell you how cbn has helped me but we
ain't got the time you got to trust me
on this one go to cbdline.com right now
pressing code joey or church and get 20
off and cbd gets delivered right to your
crib that's showy or church to get 20
off on cbd lion
order it right now the joint is also
brought to you by a [__] tremendous
pair of sweats public wreck sweatpants
used to only be worn by high school gym
teachers and unemployed moocs at the bus
stop but public wrecks sweatpants are
into the 21st century i [__] love
these things
listen they only sent me two pairs i
wish they would have sent me 50. they
got little zippers on the side and the
back you won't lose your [__] you know
you put like the sweats i have in today
when i go to the gym i put my phone in
the side to track the steps it falls out
now with
now with public wreck sweatpants they're
comfortable and stylish you gotta get
public wreck sweatpants they're where
athletic wear meets leisure it's a
sweatpants that tailored to fit you like
a nice pair of [__] pants you are
gonna be in shock you can wear these
anywhere work happy hour the gym the
barbecue it's made in all sizes get the
best-selling all-day
pant available in 40 different sizes
so it will fit all kinds of guys even if
you're built like a michelob bottle
don't worry about nothing public wreck
has yet here's my favorite part the
pockets have zippers nothing is falling
out plus they make shorts t-shirts
jackets and even golf wear you got to
look sharp dog it's 2021
[__] with slinging dick and you're
still wearing those beat up sweatpants
like some [__]
public wreck rarely discounts but right
now they have an exclusive offer just
for the joint family you ready go to
public rec dot com preston joey and get
10 percent off that's public wreck
p-u-b-l-i-c wreck r-e-c
dot com use promo code joey to get 10
off sling dick in style and comfort with
public wreck let's get this party
started it's wednesday you got [__] to
do i got [__] to do
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 13th of [__]
october do me a favor
somebody call me please anybody know
where the [__] time is going where
the [__] is it going friday's going to
be the 15th
of the [__] month already where the
[__] has the month gone where's this
year gone
all i remember it being [__] fourth
of july me lighting firecrackers and a
[__]
one of those roman candles and it's
october [__] 13th
it's great i'm feeling good hope
everybody's doing well at home
[__] went to this place
last night and [__] edison called
harold's holy [__]
i wish i was exaggerating to you
[__]
the sandwich is possibly nine inches
[__] tall
i've never seen anything like this yeah
it's this [__] big
you go with six people even the waiter
will say just order a sandwich for two
you're like but there's six of us he's
like trust me just order a sandwich for
two
holy [__]
i went off my weight watcher points i
mean i blew the [__] system last
night if you get a chance to go to
harold's and [__] edison
the onion rings the [__] listen
it's the best jewish deli i've been to
since [__] cats
and you guys know i love [__]
pastrami i kept it light a couple ounces
you know but i had to eat a [__]
onion ring and i had to get the [__]
mushroom barley you know i'm down with
the jews from day one jack they had
kegel they had all that jew food i was
like what the [__] and it just wasn't it
was delicious the [__] dessert if you
got a chance to go there i got to tell
you something [__] that i'm
really proud of jersey got some good ass
food i mean
good ass food you know south jersey holy
[__]
i mean i am very very very [__]
impressed guys and it's you know me i
look to talk [__] about somebody's
restaurant but dog they don't even give
me a [__] opportunity to down here
everything is good even the [__] wawa
when ari came down here he was so
excited that there was a wawa i had a 35
gift certificate in my car i had to give
it to him he was like oh my god it was
like giving him a [__] uh you know a
a [__]
receipt to like what do what do you call
those coupons you give people like gifts
to a restaurant like it was like giving
him like a [__] thing to rails or
something he was so [__] excited over
a gift card you get gas
he loves the sandwiches in there like
people the [__] pretzels oh my god
mikey brings me the pretzels
some nights i get super [__] stoned i
put them in the microwave oven i put a
little hot mustard on those
[__] oh
what or i you know me i'm a hillbilly
i'll dip those [__] in olive
oil so when i wake up in the morning i
[__] nice
you know what i'm saying
that that 10 points for the whole press
or you either half but it's only five
you got to use your head [__] you
know what i'm saying who the [__] you
think you're dealing with joey bananas i
[__] i'm having a hard
time sleeping
like three nights in a row i didn't know
what it was and i'm like oh it's time i
smoked that pipe i got to bang it out
with the [__] joint last night i went
back with the joint i got some of that
[__] laughing gas i put some keith in
that [__] i rolled that
[__] up and i went in the front
and smoked it holy [__]
i came downstairs i don't even know how
i talked on the phone last night i
[__] blacked out again
i'm starting to feel like that chick
that died what's her name the singer i
gotta go to rehab i'm telling you dog
i'm like amy winehouse junior i'm
blacking out at night off a reefer no
nothing nothing else
i do some edibles you know i do like
i do the tea which is two milligrams i
do
three abx capsules which is
sometimes i put an extra one in there
for good luck you know what i'm saying
like you don't want to slip on the way
to bed you want a little [__]
a little extra 400 for good luck i'm out
of the tincture the farm's tincture but
i got the syringes so before i was using
a syringe the whole [__] syringe and
the tea that's a waste that's overkill
all i gotta do is i can split the
syringe now into four nights if you're
looking to make that michael jackson t
you could split you get a syringe from
[__] whatever forms and i just put
like maybe two tents in there that's it
and guys
it's over i put the tea i make a regular
cup of tea i put an ice cube in there
for it to cool off so i don't have to
sit there like grandma for two hours
drinking tea sipping it i don't need
that in my life burning my tongue and
[__] burn the roof of my mouth one day i
took it because then i take the tea bags
out and i suck on them for a while like
i just suck on them like they're nuts
i put one on this side and one on this
side and i just sit there watching tv
just a little bit under my gum i suck
everything out of those [__] tea bags
because the tincture and [__] goes into
the tea bag so i drink everything out of
the tea bag
and then i stir it up good the tea and i
down that [__] the joint is
rolled before i even go upstairs to
prepare the tea you know me dawg the
joint is rolled at like 9 30. i don't
want no misunderstandings i go from the
t
to the porch and i smoke my [__] bone
oh my god i'm loving it guys i don't
need to smoke in the daytime no more a
lot of you guys drew me out of the
church
if you're not hired by two o'clock go
[__] yourself i get it hey i'm against
the rules but i'm doing my own
[__] rules i'm down to one
[__] number a day at night that's
tremendous guys
especially coming where i was coming
from i was smoking 82 [__]
thousand bongs a day and that was just
the bongs
never mind the [__] hits i hit that
freeze pipe again the other night that's
not a bad
oh that's not a bad when lee told me he
wasn't coughing anymore i knew there was
something in it because i remember when
i lived in colorado i never [__]
coughed and i was in that high altitude
i got to tell you something that [__]
pipe that great little [__] pipes
i'll give you the bunk because i'm not
going to use the big bung i use the
little one the one i show them i use the
little one
that thing hits like a [__] mule
that'll kick you right the [__] i've
never been a big bomb guy
the big bongs are nice but a they break
they're big and b
i've always felt that the little mules
do the best job you get yourself
an 18-incher and smaller that little
[__] one i don't like the the [__]
bong that's a that's a blow job that's a
die-hard but the [__]
the bubbler yeah i like the big uh the
medium [__] whatever i don't like the
little i don't mind having a bubbler but
it's got to be a little [__] big you
know what i'm saying today's guest is
john bernthal uh i've been friends with
him
since grudge match he was on the church
um
i've never been friends with a leading
man before
um we speak all the time you know we got
tight after grudge match and we got
tighter on the bond during the sopranos
it was great to have him you know he's
just a great guy to have around
he's knowledgeable as [__] he knows
everything about actor acting
and he's just a great [__] actor uh
as you guys know i'm not a good actor
i'm a mediocre actor
but i work hard so
i make it seem like i'm doing something
but uh
this guy is just great he's been a great
friend to me
um
great ha like i said it's great having a
[__] leading man
as a dear friend you could ask him
questions i'll never be a leading man
so uh it doesn't [__] matter i love
this guy with all my heart
he's got a new movie out that he uh sent
me the other night
and he knew he knows my taste i mean
we've talked about all the movies i like
he hit it right on the [__] head with
this movie i've watched this movie twice
and i was about to watch it again last
night but it was just getting too late i
was watching the dodger
san francisco game so i didn't really
want to
[__] that up
i enjoyed it man this is one of those
more i like small time movies i mean i
like big movies too but the
the best way i've learned about acting
is by doing
small production movies you know when
you do a big movie like spider-man 2
people opening up the doors for you you
have eight people gushing around you
tucking your shirt in making sure oh you
have a little hair over here shape that
you do 100 a day movie or a low budget
movie or a movie that the budget's not
that high a lot of those people aren't
on the set you gotta you gotta [__]
do it all yourself so it's a big
education i had a podcast yet i was on
some
girls podcast yesterday sweet girl
jessica
and i was explaining to her that you
know years ago
like i had been in 20 [__] things i
got 75
acting credits guys
you know i should know a thing of
[__] two i didn't even know i didn't
count them the guy chuck counted him and
uh when he brought me up at the q a in
uh in town and whatever i have 75
credits you learn [__] after a [__]
while
but i told jessica yesterday on the
podcast when i was doing her when i was
on there that
i did general hospital [__] years ago
if i would have got that call for
general hospital when i moved to l.a i
would have been fine
they don't talk to you on that set they
don't say nothing you check in they tell
you what room you're in and that's it
there's a monitor on the wall that tells
you when to go out when to rehearse when
to come back then they'll bring you back
out again you don't even have
you go out there you say the lines to a
soap opera like let's say i'm doing a
scene with mike and i [__] up a line we
start the scene from the top on the soap
opera they don't even give you that
they started from that line pick it up
from where you felt oh okay uh charlie
let's go you know that type of [__] and
they rush you out of there you're like
you're gone okay that's it i was there
was days i was getting there at eight
and i was in my car at 9 15.
like they don't [__] around they rap at
five
so if you're thinking about getting into
acting me and mike were talking about
this early how yeah when you're a
musician
we're told that you have to be a
musician in a band and tour not really
there's other type of musicians there's
people that make millions of dollars
that you don't even see
you've never even heard that makes
jingles you know how much money there is
in [__] jingles what's that one the
jeopardy jingle that guy gets like 64
000 a week
i think it's uh one of the guys that
created all those shows
he also created the jingles to those
shows this company
marv something merv or something like
that his company is [__] huge so just
because you're not touring doesn't mean
it's like right now i'm looking for a
content writer job
that's the same thing as doing comedy
you're writing
wow who's not better who's better than
[__] you for a content job that's me
that's what i'm looking for a little
content writer job to describe i have a
friend that was a big time director
and one day he just quit you know what
he does he directs the videos to how to
build [__] for costco no for uh in ikea
he's been there
for 15 [__] years
happy as a pig and [__] he's home by
five o'clock so
always you know don't give up if you're
a musician and your band's [__] up
who cares just create jingles and make
millions of dollars and you don't get bd
who's better than you
enjoy john bernthal [__]
[Music]
what's up beautiful what's up my man
what's up my man
how are you joey's good to see you man
great to see you i saw you on the red
carpet
and then they made me [__] go in and
i didn't see anybody you know i gotta
tell you man you know i i i saw you
there
i saw you there i'm still i'm on and
your eyes connected joe i i man i love
you so much i love you too you've always
been so good to me i like
you know it's crazy because then i spent
the rest of the night there at that
[__] party looking around for you
trying to find you and and i was so
bummed that we didn't get to see each
other you were the guy i was looking for
but you know we did you know it's like
we it was like a old school romance
movie you me you know we locked eyes and
i see and it's you know sometimes man
everything that needs to be expressed
can be expressed in a look man i i you
know i felt you and i saw it i just i
just wish you know what even today i
just wish that i got to be with you you
know what i mean
it was great though it was great seeing
you
it was great seeing you on the big
screen you know it's [__] great man
how are you i'm good man i'm good you're
so good in that movie man so are you you
were great
i love that boo hoo i still say them i'm
saying boo hoo to everybody now when you
boo hoo junior i [__] loved it boo
hoo
look at dickie maltesanti he [__] his
dad died and he stepped up his [__]
[__]
you drove that [__] guy that killed
dicky [__]
with the boohoo
how's this new movie you're shooting
you're enjoying it
yeah it's good man you know here here in
baltimore man it's uh
you know it's it's a it's a really uh
it's a i'm really honored to be a part
of it man you know
david simon george pelicanos those guys
are heroes to me
you know i'm making it with this guy
named ray green who directed the uh this
movie king richard i got coming out
about um serena and venus and their dad
richard williams
uh uh you know i love this guy i'm
making it with i i love this town it's a
beautiful city it's a brutal city um
it's got so much heart uh i'm so
grateful to the people here for for
embracing me and it's a sensitive story
about sensitive stuff but you know the
people in the police department here and
the people in the community here they've
really welcomed me in and and it's uh
that's a real honor for me joey
i know you love all that [__] you love
it you you're the real deal man
listen since i became frenzy i started
watching your work
and i'm watching it to learn you know
with the [__] eyeball to learn i
can't tell you
how much i love that punisher i cannot
[__] tell you
i cannot tell you i look at i want to
ask you some questions about how intense
was the
training before
what did what disciplines did you train
and you were [__] [__] up in
that show
i mean look joe you know the training
part you know you know the the weapons
you know the stuff i do with taran out
of tear and tactical you know those
those guys are the greatest the the
weapons training and obviously the you
know i've done the fight training you
know most of my life and and with
kerrigan who you know and love and and
uh and then you know i'm i'm
look man
the folks from the military kevin vance
from the navy seals tyler gray the guys
i've gotten to meet along the way and
been part of my training and everything
you know i'm i'm just uh
i'm so grateful to him and and and and
the training look that's i i mean i
don't mean to be i don't know what the
word is i i don't i don't mean to be uh
cute about it
you know that's the fun part that's the
easy part you know i i i think the
training i i think you know the the the
tough thing there is is you know it's
really at its core it's about a a man
who's who's who's lost his wife and kids
that they were taken from him and and
you know like you man my family's
everything i i i until you know what
it's like
to to uh have this profound love this
love where you you you'd absolutely in a
second give your life for them for your
kids for your wife um until you
understand what that's like you can't
even begin to start to imagine what it
would be like to lose that and that's a
if you really want to approach that
realistically that's a that's a dark
road to go down uh it's a dark road to
go down and and i think the hard part of
that
is that you gotta
you gotta play that you gotta respect
that you gotta do that honestly you
gotta go to those
places and and and and also man look
this character means so much to the the
comic book audience to to law
enforcement to military and and that's
enormously important to me it was
enormously important to me to to look if
you say you want to do it right i don't
know how to do it right i just know how
to kind of give it my all and and and
that's what i wanted to make sure that i
did the entire time and and uh that's
the only part we can that's the only
part in this business and in this job
that we can kind of control is giving it
our all is effort and dedication
it's really crazy when it comes to
acting i came from the stand-up school
but i grew up
loving movies i love film i love sitting
in a movie theater the whole i have a
process i have to eat chinese food i
have to smoke a joint
i like going to the movies by myself
really too because people are painting
the ass so i like going movies i i've
always held sacred
you put
like i've never i've been to acting
class and i've you know done little
things but your level of commitment to
acting i could definitely see it on the
big screen
i don't know if you could understand
that but your commitment and i really
saw it in this in the many saints
i saw a little bit of it in the punisher
i saw a lot of it in small engine repair
you're a powerful [__] actor
you know
look joey i i i i appreciate it i
appreciate you saying it and i say it
right back to you but don't you think
the whole thing i mean look when you
really think about stand up and and what
you guys do
you know i have so much admiration and
respect for it because you guys are
flirting with disaster every time like
the the the the the courage that it
would take to go up there and not only
risk bombing but but embrace it embrace
that risk
what do you got for me what are you guys
there danger here all right i'm gonna
run towards it i think this thing that
we do we've gotta find that we always
gotta find
the danger we always gotta embrace the
the the real palpable risk
of of a failure and a fallen flat on our
face taking that big risk i think we got
to do it and i think that that comes
really for me it's it's training it's
dedication but it's also just living
life man it's living life it's being
been gone through [__] growing changing
uh uh uh
you know sticking your
you know seeking adventure in the way
that you've lived your life
understanding that you're going to fail
admitting your failures you know going
down some pretty dark roads and then
trying to come out the other end of them
and when i look at you and i look at
your life and i look at the kind of
artists you are you you embody that you
embody that
absolute honesty at all times absolute
honesty at all times where you live your
life is the way you do your art yeah
i'll tell you man
a guy just sent me this morning
coincidentally i was gonna i knew i was
gonna do your show
and uh some guy just sent me this this
youtube video of the last time i was on
i guess this actor who was in episode
one of the walking dead posted this clip
from our uh from from our interview when
when i was on your show and i talked
about uh
an experience that i'd gone through when
i kind of hit a rock bottom and i'd made
a big mistake and we talked about sort
of changing your life and turning a
negative into a positive and uh you know
man i love your audience you don't know
how many people saw that episode and
have come to me and said you know i i
made a big mistake and i went through a
dark time and i turned it into a
positive and i think only folks that
have been through that can really talk
about that and and can articulate that
and can then provide hope to folks who
are actually going through that and
you're that guy joey and i'm i'm i'm
just really grateful for for that
conversation i'm grateful that folks
have come up to me and said that that
actually had an impact we're not here
just
you know i mean look man we want to make
people laugh we want to have a a good
conversation but if through this you
actually get to reach somebody and and
and give them a little bit of a hope if
they're in a in a tough time it it's
beautiful man and and i think your story
in the way you conduct yourself for me
it's it's it's inspiring and people have
no idea what it's like to be on set with
you what a gift that is you get a front
row ticket to joey d you you understand
we're shooting the show then you get to
sit in the back room or on the among the
chairs normally i just stay in character
i stay with it but i was like a magnet
to those chairs because i get to hear
joey just cracking everybody i mean the
crowd people don't understand how big of
a gift it is to be on set with you man
it was fun it was were long [__]
nights and we got into some great
conversations
with uh
the guy from uh
the brother he was great late night
he was talking some fun he was dropping
some troops too uh
the guy that yeah harold oh leslie
leslie is [__] we had some great
talks at night he was
he's a deep [__] dude i didn't know
he could sing but the thing that you me
that guy is really talented the thing
that you me and him have in common
we love what we do and we opened up our
world
to take advice
we
you appreciate your audience
nobody appreciated hates their audience
more than me
they made me become a better comic and a
better person because i knew they were
there that's right i knew they were
there they're there they're there
watching you they're there watching your
every move
to make sure you're not a flash in the
pan or you're bullshitting them or
you're a hypocrite i've been with them
and i love them if you love if somebody
gives you love how you receive you've
got to give that love right back and you
got to give it back
it's valuable and they're coming to see
joey diaz that that means something
means something to them so it means
something to you of course when you walk
on that set
i'm thinking about my performance but
i'm also thinking about
my behavior and i'm thinking about the
people that are coming to see that movie
they're going to have to get a
babysitter
they're going to have to drive they're
going to have to do so much to go see
that [__] movie
i get all that i got that from comedy
they're going to get a baby on top of
the [__] [__] you're hitting them
with you know the the popcorn and the
[__] raisin that's for 22.50
and the whole [__] thing
they got to go through a babysitter
they're going to go out to dinner right
you're going to take your wife out to
dinner before you go to a movie there's
all these things you got to do so i
appreciate them
doing that i know how hard it is to say
goodbye to your daughter and your son
i'm going to see some [__] stupid
movie or whatever
i consider all that [__]
so i want to be the best when i used to
do comedy yeah i would do the spots at
the store
yeah and people are not going to believe
the story but i'll tell you how [__]
shitty i am as a [__] comic
i would do spots
because i never wanted to bomb on the
weekend
so what i did was i did more sets so the
percentages would be in my favor
so a lot of comics just go out on the
weekends and then they'll bomb on the
road one show don't go one out of five
shows they'll bomb
i didn't want to do that to my audience
so i'd rather take a bomb on a tuesday
or thursday because i know it's coming
you got to know it's coming once you put
your hands up i don't care how good a
defense what's that ratio what's that
ratio how much when how many shows you
expect a bomb out of like if you do 10
shows are you definitely gonna have a
bomb two out of ten no really yeah i
don't give a [__] who you are except the
odds it's you or what the audience no i
i've never seen you bomb your life
you well we're over critical you're over
critical you look at it you watch a
movie and you do something wrong with
your hand you beat yourself up of course
you do a bad choice you beat yourself up
more than me
no no and that's what you need to do you
need to beat yourself up that's right
you know when you're driving home when i
had to drive up laurel canyon that's a
beating
that's a [__] beating that's a
beating that your father would give you
you got to get your life together you
got to step up they're giving you this
opportunity you're going to be a [__]
the rest of your life you're going to be
a [__] the rest of your life you just
ate a bag of dicks don't let it happen
again you know that's the talk
but when you're a performer when you're
a baseball player you back 364. there's
a percentage
so
i'd rather go out during the week and
take a break to the [__] head on a
tuesday then take a break to the head
when those people have a babysitter yeah
and when they really can sometimes i
didn't bomb on a tuesday and sometimes i
didn't bomb on a thursday
so i knew i had to work extra hard i had
to go my set list before i got on stage
backwards and frontwards you know even
though i i make it look organic
that's the whole thing is making it look
organic i want them to think that i said
it for the first time i've said it three
thousand times
of course of course
that's where we're at brother that's it
that's it that's it i'm with you and
that's your love and i could see it in
your work and that's the most important
thing that people have to see if you
call it in
people will see that too i remember one
night i opened up for rogan
wasn't prepared
and somebody came up to me after the
show and they said dog you called it in
it destroyed me your original feeling is
to punch him in the mouth
but then you're like that's to punk in
me that punk doesn't exist anymore
he came to me to told me to tell me a
real thought
he knows that he expected more from me
and i called it in
sure so he came up to me and told me the
truth he's actually a good friend good
friend tells you the truth no matter
what that's the only kind of friend you
want and this guy wasn't a friend he was
a guy in the audience that paid 25 bucks
or 40 bucks or whatever he paid to see
rogan
and he got a piece of [__] from me and i
agree with him that night i went up to
the room and i was furious you know
that's if you don't get furious there's
a problem it's like people who say well
how do you still get butterflies if you
don't get butterflies you shouldn't be
in there that's right if you put me in
the ring with a four-year-old i'm gonna
get butterflies
because i know i'm gonna get hit well
i'm gonna get kicked i'm gonna kick him
i might beat him his ass
he's four
i might pull his [__] hair
this small engine repair tremendous
movie
i saw it twice started watching again
last night i'm trying to figure out with
the wife how to
connect it to the tv so he could see it
because i'm a [__] idiot
i had to sit there great story great
acting
when is this coming out
so it's so it's uh it was in theaters
and now it's just coming out it's going
to be on demand it's going to be on
video on demand now for a few weeks and
then it'll come out in hulu i think next
month so you can see it on demand now
uh
you know look
you know it's a movie
it's a real passion project we did that
as a play 10 years ago in l.a in a
40-seat theater and a late night piece
me and john uh you know the guy who who
started in the movie he wrote it and
directed it too
you know he's a guy from new hampshire
you know it's look it's about the kind
of guys they don't really make movies
about anymore you know just blue collar
real guys um and it's really really
explores a father's love for his kid i
know you understand that and what you do
nobody's perfect in that movie you know
it's it's very much about the gray area
and it's about you know sometimes the
way we talk you know you get joking
around with guys you say things but then
sometimes it goes a little bit too far
it sort of explores that then sometimes
it gets dangerous and nowadays with all
the pressure on these young kids with
social media i don't want to give away
nothing in the story but it shows how
one thing can kind of lead to another
how and the difference between just
talking a little [__] and when it
actually gets toxic and when it gets
actually very dangerous and um and what
that does to these guys and the way that
they handle it is imperfect you know
there's no
that's the kind of stories i love it's
not about good guys and bad guys it's
all very gray but very honest and i
think you know this writer john pallano
you know
when i was in trouble the thing that i
talked about the last time you know i
came on i was in depositions i had done
see right after season one of the
walking dead ten years ago a buddy of
mine called me up and he said hey listen
you want to come do this play reading
tonight i'm like listen buddy i'm i'm in
deposition it's all that's the last
thing in the world i want to do come on
come on you got to come do it so i
agreed to do it i show up it's the last
thing i want to do you got all these
theater folks around i see john pilano
there he's sitting there i go what have
i got myself into we read this thing out
loud and i never heard writing like this
i mean i i think he's the best american
playwright since david manning i said to
him after i said let's do this he said
we could do it at a teeny theater here
in l.a it's just 40 seats i said i'm in
let's go i'm in right now we did it the
play exploded it became it won all the
awards in la then we moved it to new
york off broadway blew up and it was
always
this passion project for john and i that
we would make it into a movie and you
know 10 like 10 years later we finally
did um you know everybody who'd ever
done the play has roles in the movies
you know my dog who was in the was
backstage at the original play he came
and was in the movie this dog played him
in flashbacks you know we it was a real
labor of love and i think you said it
when we talked about it the first time
they just don't make it's an old-school
movie it's funny it'll it's it's a
thriller it changes on a dime and um i
really think it it it's uh we're proud
of it man we're proud of it i'm really
glad that you watch i knew you'd like it
it's about everything i love friends
and my daughter and kit you know a kid
you know
i really love friendship i'm a [__]
student of friendship i love
you know i was telling
the podcast people i went to the
carnival in my hometown saturday night
and people were asking me like what are
you doing here
like why are you here do you have a limo
driver where's your security
and i'm like are you [__] kidding me
i came up here again as a labor of love
my buddy runs the carnival
he runs that park i wanted to see him
but when i got there they didn't want
anything from me
they didn't want to hear nothing all
they wanted was to take a picture in
love and they were giving me love
what a beautiful opportunity oh my god
what what's better than that you know
you know i
when i was i was just home a couple
weeks ago and i got to go to the nordoff
high school football game in my hometown
you know
i live in a small town of ojai
california there's no place i'd rather
be take my kids to the game and and you
know to see the community be out there
you know we spend so much time on the
road so much time where you know we're
just you know we got to be somewhere
every second we got to be on we got it's
just great to uh i don't know just to to
to to be around folks and and and
and to get to connect with people uh
it's it's such a gift and and and i know
that's who you are man
it's what you're doing everything and
we're really lucky man we're really
lucky that we get to uh that you know
just the fact that you go and take a
picture with somebody means something to
that i can't i still understand i can't
believe it you know i couldn't believe
it myself i couldn't believe it myself
they didn't want anything they didn't
want to talk about nothing they just
wanted love they were happy to see me
after 40 years tons of people
i hadn't seen since high school my
friend's band who the first time i saw
my buddy look that i went to dinner with
before the carnival looked at me and he
goes it's like being in the shed when we
were in high school he had a shed and
we'd go there and all of us would play
the drums and [__]
and i turned around and goes no
this goes back to the rec center in the
seventh grade
when he was playing the guitar and this
[__] guitar string broke
and i died a laugh and i'm like why am i
laughing that dude's up there doing
something i'm over here a spectator with
these jerk-offs drinking beers and
smoking pot and i became friends with
him and now we're dear friends and
his mom was there you know what it's
like to see his mom
after 30 years and i went up to her and
thanked her for all the meals all this
[__] she put up with it and her shed
that his shed we painted the walls pink
floyd the wall
had no heat
there was no [__] heat back there and
we would go back there when it was 20
below
yeah with our drinking gloves with the
fingertips out with the [__] drinking
gloves and that was it those are what
kids do in jersey you know that's why i
moved back here i wanted my daughter
to have this life friends
friends
people who live and die for you people
who come over and talk to your kid at
three o'clock
this [__] basement is packed
once they get off the bus
they all walk down here
i love it and they [__] play and they
talk you got to come down with apple
juices and
tell them to knock it off don't touch
the guitar your [__] because the kid up
the corner my uncle was a guitar i don't
give a [__] don't touch the guitar [__]
sucker he's a great kid they're great
kids
but uh this is my life this is i love
this [__] i love it and you're right you
know i i think this thing about for you
you know when i look at the guys i grew
up with
they're still my best friends in the
world and even being here in baltimore
i'm closer to dc so every chance i get
you know i'm back there with dougie to
all all the guys that i grew up with and
and uh
you you know it's it's i think as you
get older
especially when you start to have kids
of your own
you recognize you're nothing
your friends you know it's funny i'm
doing this show right here now that i
told you about baltimore and the other
day
i i was working nights and during the
day i shot down in baltimore and i just
i needed to go see my friend dougie
thornell i went to his house i go i get
outside his house i just lean on the
horn right i just lean on the horn
outside his house i see him look out the
window like who's this and then he sees
me screws what are you doing i didn't
tell him i was coming i say doug i'm not
going to tell you to see but i was doing
this crazy scene i mean my character the
thing that he was doing that day was
nuts i said hey this is a kid who was
raised on television he had a milk creek
that he used to sit on he sit like this
far away from the television knows every
line from every movie and i go dougie
this is what i'm doing in the scene
today give me what would i say what
should i say here he gave me this line
i'm telling you joey it was [__] i mean
it was just fire i gave him a hug you
know it's like we're nothing without
them like he i i would rather talk to
him than any writer any director in
hollywood he you know he gets it he gets
it and he gets me you know what i mean
it's uh it's a great feeling man when
you could and when i got back here i had
some friends that were [__] jackals
you know there's some friends that
haven't stopped to [__] grind
and i had to tell them like listen guy
it ain't that type of party no more you
know call me when you
want to changes you know but there's a
handful of guys that have accepted me
we talked constantly tonight i'm going
to a friend's house to watch the dodger
[__] san francisco game
you know people like why aren't you
doing comedy because i'm filling the
void with other things right now i'll
get back to comedy eventually yeah but
right now i just got i'm in a thing that
nobody knows
i haven't seen in years it's called the
community that's beautiful i'm part of a
community i was at a softball game my
daughter's softball game last night
sitting on the side 15 parents they're
passing enterman's donuts around
you know it's a different [__] world
i'm living for your daughter man i mean
there's nothing there's that's the thing
there's no job more important than that
it's the bits that it's the most
important job you're ever going to have
raising these kids it's it's the biggest
gift it's the only chance you're really
going to understand beauty you're going
to understand failure you're going to
understand hope you're going to you the
the love is so big and so beyond
anything and that's that i imagine
that's why you're doing it it's the only
reason and and you know i'll tell you
with the whole friendship thing and and
just in terms of that movie you know i
just want to say i'm glad that that's
the term that you you use because it's a
really hard thing i think to get on
screen for real when you see real
friends the way you joke with each other
the way you know each other secrets the
way you can attack each other because
you know each other so well and you know
shay and i have known each other a
really long time it's his daughter uh
george a brilliant actress who's in the
punisher shea and i worked together a
long time ago but we've been long-term
friends john and i been friends for 10
years and the three of us the bond was
so tight everybody's kids were on the
movie everybody who had ever played all
our circle of friends came in and did
little bit parts you know kerrigan was
there i saw characters it was great you
know they were all there they were all
part of it you know my um it was such a
a labor of love and i i think when you
what when the set you know when you go
when you approach something with that
with that in your heart that this should
be a place where about love and
friendship and family you know that was
how the entire thing was run and i
really do think it comes out on the on
the screen
it does
it really does
now which one was shay the guy that was
in narcos
yeah
the guy who plays uh [__] okay
yeah yeah the third of yeah yeah and he
was you know he's a brilliant actor you
know boardwalk empire and wolf of wall
street he's he's he's like one i mean
he's he's a genius that guy
he is a [__] genius he really is he's
in a lot of [__] he's worked a lot over
the years
uh what did you think of many saints
first of all
what happened when you saw de niro
anything
man well you know i you know i gave him
a hug
you know
i haven't you know i haven't really seen
him since since uh you know we work with
him down in new orleans you know what i
mean and it was so great to see him and
i mean you know i mean that night was
just so magical you know him
introducing it and and just being in the
king's presence like that you know uh
but look i you know i was that was my
first time seeing the movie i i was
really uh it was such a perfect night
and such a perfect audience for it you
know i i was blown away by the work i
was blown away i thought the movie was
beautiful i thought it was shot
beautifully i thought the story was
great i thought the performances were
just incredible when you look at vera
and you look at leslie and you look at
corey and alessandro i mean just such
brilliant performances but i think you
know my big takeaway honestly was mikey
it was just mikey i i i i uh you know
this whole thing for me
i i've been blown away michael
gandolfini since i met him you know he
came to me before this thing started up
in ojai
and he came to me he approached this
thing with so much humility and respect
and reverence and he
he was in this process he told me of
trying to get to know his father better
and and he was sort of traveling the
country getting to talk to all these
people that had worked with him and and
been with him and been real friends of
his
and then you know he takes on this role
and and what a
i mean i mean when you
just to try to put your
your heart around the magnitude of what
that must felt like for him uh
you know i was just staggered by the way
he approached it the whole way and and
how hard he worked and how kind he was
he never let the pressure get to him and
and then go through this entire press
process of everybody asking these
questions that it's not like you and me
oh so what was it like to work with joe
it's not like this [__] you know
they're talking to him about you know
real [__] about his life and about loss
and and the courage and dignity that he
approached that all with um
and then you see the performance man and
you don't see actors that he came in
with the dialect down with the with the
mannerisms down with the physicality
down he took a big swing he didn't
approach this like some power there was
nothing safe about that performance and
he did it and i was so
happy for him i love this kid so much i
mean when you think about i mean you
know him like i know him when you think
that how old that kid is i mean i go to
him for advice i mean such a wise young
man you know such a lived young man and
and uh i i really um that was my
favorite part it was just seeing michael
and seeing that that worked and that
tony soprano will forever live in the
gandolfini family that is that is
beautiful for me man beautiful i'll tell
you there's a scene in the movie that
killed me
and that's when you get out of jail and
he comes up to you and says i miss you
dad
it [__]
punched me in the stomach the first
second and third time i saw the movie
four times
i saw the premiere the screening and
then two q and a's
in jersey and i the first two times was
to watch the movie
the second time was to focus on you know
that you just focus on the acting i want
to learn i'm i'm a student too you know
and it was [__] brilliant i i look i
loved everybody's performance i thought
everybody did a great job you know and i
got to be honest with you john i would
never say that i thought i did a good
job and i never think i did a good job
and
when i was sitting that also dawned on
me how i felt like a band
i felt like a band because
when you do your first album as a band
that's your whole life
that's why people have so much hard
times with the second album
because they just got a year to do it
the first time you've had 30 [__]
years [__] it better be [__]
good
you know you've had all your life to
prepare this first down you've been
preparing it for five [__] years in
reality that's why it's so good but joe
you were flawless in them i mean you you
add i mean like when you brought to it's
just so much reality and then the humor
and then this this character that's so
lived in and and look man i saw what you
had like i remember man i remember in
new orleans you know the state that you
were in you know making that and brother
like
i saw you go through this process how
committed you were and how uh
just present you were and you were you
you you were you were only about that
felt like when we were making that movie
you were just about it i remember even
that day the reshoot when we came back i
had to make that speech and you could
tell i was you know i was doing another
movie at the time i mean the whole time
i was making that movie i was always
running off to be doing something else i
i nev i always felt like i was just
coming in and and you came to me and i
don't know if you remember this but you
said you you settled me man you came to
me you're like you're doing great just
stay in it you came in and and you were
there for me in a way that i felt that i
got to be there for you in new orleans
what was that 10 years ago
dude you're that guy you know like you
you were an anchor like you if you
wanted to look at something that you
absolutely believed in that movie look
at joe just go talk to joey it'll get
you i mean i even talk to you for two
seconds i start talking like you you
know what i mean like that's your
personality and how how undeniable it is
and uh you should be so proud of
yourself man it it was really your work
in the movie is phenomenal you know i
was like it took me
20 [__] years to get ready for this
movie that's right like i was
legitimately honest with people like i
worked 30 years 20 i'd done comedy 30
years 28 at the time i worked 28 years
to get ready for this movie i took 28
years of comedy lessons acting lessons
watching movies watching performances
you know i was
i mean i was the biggest gandalfini fan
there is i love i studied
all his movements when i got the
audition
i remember that i go i got this because
i got this first piece
from watching the sopranos it was
david chase type audition where he
didn't give you the right lines he only
gave you one line that counted so i knew
i had to say that one line
right people had talked spoken to me
about his audition pro like uh
sam was on a couple weeks ago
a little [__] and he was saying that he
sent them an audition for like
grungy grungy wasn't even in the [__]
movie
there was no character named grungy he
was [__] with you but i knew that one
line he had used that before
in the series
not the line
but the way he had to deliver that line
the music was on
music was on so
there was an episode where they're in uh
adriana's office
and springsteen is on
and they're about to do something tony
stops and he goes sylvia
listen
that was for them
that wasn't you know i'm saying if you
picked that up so with me
the scene was
sinatra my mother met his mother i had
to point up and go
and that was it
that was it and i got that from the
series i love james gandolfini and
michael i think
hit it out of the park
and what we're trying to say is he hit
it out of the park in more ways than one
that's right this just wasn't an acting
job this was an acting job for us
for michael it was therapy yeah it was a
personal challenge it was phenomenal on
the mountain yeah i mean it was uh yeah
exactly i think that's a really good way
to put i'm with you on that
talk to me about the serena williams
movie because that movie i'm waiting for
it that's the movie of the year i have a
funny feeling that
i'm telling you man it's so special bro
it's this one's going to be so special i
mean this
this uh this story you know look man for
guys like us you know i remember when i
first met ray green the director of the
movie
you know he's an ex-athlete like we are
you know he's he's he's a father he's a
family guy and he's a really committed
artist you know he's a
you know he's a uh
he's a new york guy
this movie is like a meditation on
fatherhood and and it celebrates family
um but there's nothing corny about it
it's so real and so inspiring and so um
it's it's it's just it's beautifully and
authentically made man i'm um i it's i i
can't remember ever being this proud of
a movie and a group of people will smith
is gonna blow your socks off i mean he's
just uh
what what he does here is just crazy man
and and i i really just everyone's work
these these young women all the people
in the williams family
you know in this movie they just they
establish it's like what you're talking
about a band they just establish this
family dynamic
and it's just real it's just real and
it's it's it's a beautiful
sports movie with so much heart and uh
yeah i'm really i'm really proud of it
you're gonna love it i'm excited for it
it's just i i you know told me a lot
about it anthony edwards
huh
anthony anderson is that his name
anthony
the brother yeah the chunky brother from
uh hustle and flop yeah yeah yeah he i
didn't know this well he lived in l.a
and he said that he would walk to school
and see them practicing oh yeah
they lived in l.a i didn't know all this
[__] yeah they were from compton
you would just tell these young girls
you're going to be the champion of the
world you know what i mean you believe
and it's this this this exercise he had
this unique and beautiful way of
parenting that was wholly his own and he
stuck to it and it's about this thing i
think that all
families and all parents eventually go
through that you know we give so much to
our kids and we try to prepare our kids
and give them so much love and so much
preparation but at some point we got to
say go fly go fly now you've got to make
your steps and that's a hard thing to do
especially for a parent that's been so
committed to that child and this just
whittles that down and explores it in
such a beautiful honest way
um
it's it's i'm telling you man the movies
the movie's thrilling it's thrilling
when does it come out christmas right
yeah uh november november 19th is that
perfect it's a beautiful [__]
thanksgiving movie what else is going on
in your world i should know about my
brother
man you know i'm i'm just doing my thing
here in baltimore you know i i i i got a
movie coming out on um
on netflix this thing i do with sandra
bullock i think that's going to be
really special that'll come out i think
in in december then you know i did this
other thing with lena dunham
a real
uh different kind of film for me but
something i'm also really proud of
something i produced and did with her uh
she's she's she's wonderful man and um
you know then i got this new this new tv
show for showtime american gigolo and
then this thing i'm doing for hbo here
uh we own this city which is you know
again the the same creators of the wire
and and uh
it's it's a real um
it's a it's a real special project
something i'm really honored to be a
part of man and uh you know i'm i'm just
doing my thing i'm i'm away from my my
kids right now so my heart's a little
bit broken so i'm trying to make the
most out of every second that's what we
do joey when we're away from these kids
you know we have to know it's it's their
names we're putting on the work so i'm
just i'm trying to put every every ounce
that i got into the work right now and
uh and get home to him and and and get
home to him in a way where i can hold my
head high and and hopefully i get him
proud uh but i miss him man i miss him
real bad when do you go back
i'll be done um right before
thanksgiving you know perfect are you
going back at all like in between
you know
i i i don't think i'm gonna get the
break i'm gonna really try to get back
for halloween so i can take him trick or
treat i gotta get there it's just you
know we're shooting on weekends and this
one's been pretty pretty tough to get
away but but uh i'm definitely gonna try
i just don't you know i don't want to
make them any promises but but i i i'm
hoping with everything i got that i can
get home for halloween
listen man you're doing some great
[__] work out there and uh charles
bronson still needs a [__]
replacement dog i've been over here
waiting since that [__] died you
know they're trying to sell you jason
stanton [__] him
he [__] did the mechanic you can't do
that you gotta have some respect in your
career
you can't do it charles bronson movie
that's not what i'm saying i'm saying
you gotta act like charles bronson and
steve mcqueen put together you got it
dawg you're that [__] i told you
when i watched the punisher i called you
right up there was no texting
there was no good morning i was like
dawg you're the next charles bronson
it's over you got to start shooting
people at night and [__] like death
wish we got to remake well [__] bruce
willis when we made death wish i want to
shoot him now that [__] i don't
want you doing a charles bronson movie
if you're going to be a charles bronson
movie you got to kill double the amount
of people
and you got to kill him smart you know
what i'm saying i can't wait to see the
sandra bullock movie i love
sandra bullock great great person great
human being she's great in this film i
think this movie is going to be really
good i haven't seen that one but i'm
hearing really good things about it she
this time she's got to show her monkey
though
you know she's at that age
she's got it you know she's done
everything she's coached the football
team
she [__] married ben affleck in the
one movie early on it's time for her to
show a monkey this one's different i bet
you i'm gonna i'm gonna come back and
ask this one i guarantee is the side of
her you haven't seen i love her don't
get me wrong but it's everybody has to
show their monkey even the chick from
titanic had to show it
you got to show that monkey sandra
bullock i want to see it i've been a fan
for 20 years i deserve it you dirty
[__] show me that monkey you got that
austin shave to it and [__]
i love you john bernthal i love you stay
in touch with the family brother i love
you and let's connect i might drive to
baltimore if you're there till november
come see me because i got john rallo
down there with the gym we'll go down
there i need to sleep i'll take you to
dinner that okay let's go get a gyro i
know you love those [__] gyros i was
going to take you for one up here you
got some great [__] gyros when we
were shooting uh the many saints yeah
you took care of it
oh [__] and how's lauren doing
lauren's good head of security man she's
good she's not with me on this one i
just got bam bam she lauren's getting
married she met a wonderful guy he's got
like a you know they're surfing they're
out in this van they're doing their
thing and but i'm sure she sends love
man she she loves you everybody loves
you i love her to death so
take care take good care of yourself
keep putting out great [__] films
you're one of the best actors out there
and you're my brother i love you to all
my heart
always right back at you joy i'll stay
black i'll see you next couple weeks all
right i appreciate you i love you
brother thank you i love you thank you
joey thank you i'm happy you guys like
john john's a great guy if you're an
actor
look up john study john
copy john john learned how to [__]
act in russia he dedicated himself he
went to rush he got mugged the first day
to hear more about john's journey go to
the original church of what's happening
now when john was on
i'm happy you guys loved john today uh
thank you for watching the show
do not forget the download uh it's on he
told you during the uh
interview
that
uh small engine repair is on uh you
could on demand so if i was you guys i
get it's a great movie
you don't have to go to the [__]
movies you can watch it on your living
room and it's great i watched the movie
twice i'm gonna watch it again tonight
so uh enjoy it enjoy the weekend i'm
happy you [__] are here thank
you thank you for everything you do
thank you for your support
thank you for always having my back i
love you guys with all my heart
uh that's it have a great weekend
laughing gas is back in stock and i'll
see you [__] monday
the 18th of october tip top
[__] magoo ready to stab
somebody stay black have a great weekend
all right you bad [__] i'm
happy you enjoyed the podcast today i
want to thank john bernthal for coming
on
he's [__] great guys i'm happy i hope
you guys enjoy them the joint is brought
to you by my favorite sweatpants of all
time public wreck only [__] gym
teachers and unemployed [__] moocs
wore
sweatpants back in the day but public
wreck is bringing sweatpants into the
21st century
they're comfortable
they're [__] great they look great
they feel great they fit great
when you want to be comfortable and
stylish you got to go with public wreck
this is where athletic wear meets
leisure it's a sweatpants that's
tailored to fit
like a nice pair of trousers your ass
sticks out tremendous you can wear them
anywhere work happy hour with a gym a
barbecue and it's made in all sizes get
the best-selling all-day everyday pant
available in 40 different sizes so will
fit all kinds of guys
if you're built all awkward and [__]
like a cheeseburger you're gonna be fine
listen i love them they're comfortable
my wife washes them they have a little
string they got zippers that's my
favorite part nothing has fallen out of
your pants plus they make short t-shirts
jackets and even golf wear look sharp
while being comfortable who's better
than you nobody that's why you got to
get these public sweatpants these public
wreck sweatpants they're tremendous try
a t-shirt try a matching jacket but what
you need to do is go to publicrec.com
preston joey to get 10 off that's public
rec p-u-b-l-i-c
rec r-e-c
rec.com and use promo code joey for 10
off sling dick in style and comfort with
public wreck the joint is also brought
to you by c b d lion when you're looking
for cbd
the lion is as good as it [__]
gets you understand me from the bath
balls to the tablets to the tincture to
the kinesiology tape to the cream cbd
lines got you covered cbn cby
cbd and more go to cbd lion read the
third party lab results and get back to
me [__] this is the best cbd on
the market use code joey or church and
get 20 off cbd delivered right to your
[__] house who's better than
you nobody cbd lion the best the joint
is also brought to you by come on the
official sports betting partner of the
[__] nfl you want to win big
this weekend
we got you at draftkings just bet a
dollar on any nfl game
if and if it wins
uh you get a hundred dollars and free
bets if either team scores a point let's
correct that you don't even need to win
just [__] score of safety and i'll
get you a hundred and free bets if
either team scores and what you do is
you bet a little college football you
start off thursday night with tampa bay
philadelphia and then you got the
weekend to bet look at these games you
got denver against the raiders you got
buffalo against tennessee on monday
night nobody's better than you if the
sports book isn't available in your
state yet draftkings won't leave you
empty-handed everybody could play for
huge cash prizes all season long with
draftkings daily fantasy sports contest
draftkings has given all new customers a
free shot of millions of dollars listen
they're safe reliable
and they got the whole weekend made up
for you you got thursday night pro
football friday you got some playoff uh
baseball saturday you got some college
football and then i'm back monday and
sunday sunday and monday with pro
football we got you down suckers
download the draftking sportsbook app
use promo code joey throw a doll on any
nfl game and win a hundred dollars in
free bets if either team scores a point
who else does that nobody draftkings is
the best like i said reliable
convenient and you could trust them
that's promo code joey this week at
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the nfl and here's
the stuff the lawyer makes me say you
got to be 21 older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania
if they're allowed if the state is legal
we're legal new customers only for this
deal
you got to have a five dollar deposit
and a one dollar wager is required one
per customer don't be [__] greedy
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for details now if you
got a gaming problem obviously i don't
want to feed it call 1-800 gambler take
some steps
and regroup but if you don't have a
problem download the draftking
sportsbook app or the fantasy app and
let's win some [__] guitars i
want to thank cbd lion
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank public wreck
i want to thank manscaped
better help and light iv this week and i
want to thank you guys for always
supporting the joint and having our
[__] back
i love you [__] i hope you enjoy
john bernthal i've given you the whole
cast of the [__] many saints of
newark suckers i love you have a great
weekend
stay black i'll see you monday morning
the 18th tip top magoo ready to go
you